thank you all for coming uh we're going
to start in a second uh before we uh we
start I would like to thank all of you
for successfully braving the storm last
night to talk about Quantum science uh
and we're so happy to have so many
researcher uh from yell night to people
in the field and also new generation of
students and researcher and so it's
really really exciting to have all of
you here on site and now we can we can
start and we can uh have uh Michael CRA
the vice provos for research and the
William zingler professor of
Neuroscience and oftalmology and visual
science kick up the conference thank you
very much thanks
for hi good morning I will be very brief
and begin uh actually to reiterate uh
Florian's thanks to everybody who's come
to Yale from all over the country and
all over the world it's a tremendous
tribute to uh Quantum science at Yale
and to Rob and Steve and Michelle The
Influence they've had on Quantum uh
physics and Quantum engineering over the
course of the last 20 plus years so
thank you for coming um we hope that you
will learn a lot and that you will come
to appreciate not only um the quality of
the science in Quantum science that's
happened here at Yale over the last 20
years but the future prospects for
Quantum science which I think are
tremendous so thank you for coming and I
look forward to the program um so I want
to uh next pause and just remark on um I
I expect this conference to be extremely
smooth and uh easy to follow and quite
efficient in its uh processes and for
that we have to thank Floren and the a
conference and events teams he's put in
a lot of effort as well as the other
folks in in the yo Quantum Institute and
I want to make sure when if you have a
chance please acknowledge his effort and
the quality of support he is and the
actually the thoughtfulness for the for
what I think is going to be just a
tremendous uh tremendous conference so
thank you Florian and
[Applause]
team uh I just another minute or two um
Yale is uh well so those of you who
haven't been back to Yale for a little
while you may not recognize the building
you're in that's because it's a new
building in this spot was a building
that was called the Gibbs building it
was not a very high quality science
building it was torn down and this new
Yale science building was built in its
place it's a tremendous uh modern
facility for uh biological sciences the
department of molecular cular and
development theology is principally
housed in this building in addition to
this new building the Klein Tower which
some of you might recognize as the old
Klein biology Tower was completely gut
renovated and inside of it is a
beautiful conference facility on the
14th floor and actually uh dinner
tonight will be in that conference
facility on the 14th floor it's got a
beautiful view of New Haven a 360° view
the rest of that building is now housed
by the department of uh let's see
statistics and data science um
mathematics astronomy and some Physics
faculty as well so it's a computational
dry lab building it's no longer a wet
lab building but the um the sort of
co-cation of those uh departments uh
with the new Institute for the
foundations of data science I think puts
a nice Focus focus on the role and
import of data science broadly speaking
computational science in general in the
future of science at Yale so besides
those important building projects which
have occurred just over the last couple
years here at Yale I want to just note
that Quantum science is a major focus of
growth for the University it was
identified about five years ago in a
comprehensive strategic plan by our
Provo Scott stroble and many of the Yale
folks here participated in the
development of that strategic plan but
Quantum science and engineering ing in
particular was identified as an area of
future growth such that we have now
Broken Ground on a new physical sciences
and Engineering Engineering Building
complex just to the north of here so
it's the north part of Northwest block
part of this uh block of Campus um it's
a very comprehensive project that will
juxtapose and in part surround the right
lab which some of you visited yesterday
uh and in fact the shovels in the ground
right now for a new chemical safety
building which we have to build in order
to prepare the site for the physical
sciences and engineering building this
will be a 300,000 ft plus facility for
more than 40 faculty uh essentially
doubling the faculty in physical
sciences and Engineering at Yale it
includes a 12,000 sq Foot clean room
modern clean room on Bedrock a large
materials characterization core facility
a large Imaging core facility and an
advanced insation and Development Center
which will all facilitate Quantum
science Quantum engineering and Material
Science so those of you who um uh have
never been to Yale before uh the Yale
has changed dramatically in the last few
years and you can expect pretty dramatic
changes in the over the course of the
next five to 10 years including huge
investments in Quantum science and
engineering largely because of the
tradition that was established by
Michelle and Steve and uh um Rob and so
I I want to just uh pause here and um
note the amazing science that they've
done over the last 20 plus years and the
amazing um science that they they
spawned in the context of all of you
here many of you were our children or
grandchildren of Michelle Rob and Steve
and a new field of science really
Quantum Computing I think has emerged as
a result of their uh seminal
contributions so it's amazing work it's
wonderful to be able to uh pause for a
minute look back over the course of the
last 20 years what they've accomplished
and also think together about what we
might accomplish over the course of the
next 10 20 years which I think has is
essentially Limitless so thank you to
you and um I'm really looking forward to
the conference and for and so now I'd
just like to actually one more one more
final comment so tonight at dinner those
of you can make dinner there will be a
model and some posters poster boards
about the new physical scien and
Engineering Building complex up on the
14th floor you can look down on the site
where that building will be built and
tomorrow and Friday that model and
posters will be in the um in the entry
area to Marsh so you can look look at it
and see what it is that we're planning
which I think is quite
spectacular okay so now pivot to the
science which I'm sure which is what
you're all interested in learning about
so I'm going to introduce Steve gerin uh
Steve is a Eugene Higgins professor of
physics and applied physics he's also
the former Vice Provost uh for science
the position I'm fortunate to hold right
now Vice Provost for research um Steve
has made seminal contributions in
Quantum science including most of the
theoretical Concepts that underly the
engineering that that you hear more
about over the course of of the next
three years three days so Steve um
welcome and thank you for providing the
introductory uh talk for this uh for the
conference
today thanks very much Mike um we
appreciate uh you being here to
introduce the conference and also for uh
the financial support that the Provost
office uh provided through the Flint
fund so uh so this is the start of what
we hope is an exciting uh conference and
uh let me start by uh pointing out that
uh we're in the Centennial uh period of
the invention of quantum mechanics what
exact year you think is the 100th
anniversary depends on whether you're uh
French German or Austrian uh and uh 100
years to the week that verer Heisenberg
was on the island of helgoland inventing
Matrix mechanics there'll be a nice
conference there so I commend that to
you okay so um I'm going to talk about
uh kind of the brief history of circuit
QED and then talk about uh some uh new
results that we been uh uh working on
with uh our many collaborators here in
yqi so um I want to give a special
thanks to the AR for their strong
support of this burgeoning field over
the last quarter century and it's been
very important to the history that I'm
going to uh tell you about now and uh a
lot of you know the senior people will
know the history and and but some of the
younger people don't know all of the the
things shrouded in the mid of time so uh
I thought it'd be fun to go over that a
bit and uh the field started with uh
classical mechanics and the realization
that the
joseen uh equations told us that the
phase across a superconducting junction
obeyed Newton's classical law of motion
uh you could think of the phase as the
position of a
particle and uh it sits in a in a
washboard potential if you have a
current bias Junction and if it escapes
from one of the wells it begins falling
downhill and because the
um uh velocity of the particle the time
rate of change of the
phase uh is the voltage you can detect
that uh velocity and and uh for you
young people who don't know what a
washboard is Mike tinum always used to
say it's a um classical analog of a
joseen
junction
so so people started building these
circuits and doing interesting things
with them uh in a world dominated by
friction and Tony leot began asking
questions about Shing her cats and and
you know if this particle if this uh
variable acts like the position of a
particle could that particle exhibit
macroscopic Quantum
behavior and uh so uh Our Heroes John
Clark and Michelle deor and John
Martinez in
1985 decided to see if that particle um
had quantized energy levels inside these
little potential Wells
and they did that by uh spectroscopy
by kind of quantum jump spectroscopy
where you shine microwaves at the right
transition frequency and then the
particle is high enough up in the well
that it can tunnel out into a finite
voltage state so it's microwaves in and
low frequency voltage measurements
out and sure enough uh they saw peaks in
the Spectrum indicating that this
particle could be quantum
mechanical uh then uh people started
playing with Cooper pair boxes and uh
it's just a a capacitor with a a bias
voltage on it and it's a sufficiently
small capacitor that tuning this voltage
could um um uh change the average uh
number of Cooper p pairs from n to n
plus one from a billion to a billion
plus one and if you choose the bias
voltage correctly those two states can
be degenerate and because of the
coherent jodison tunneling you can go
into a superposition of those two charge
States and so
unlike uh a normal Junction the average
charge would change over a voltage range
that was controlled by the coherent
tunneling amplitude the coherent
tunneling splitting between those two
charge
States uh also in Japan uh uh yasu
Nakamura was working on this and he was
doing uh microwave measurements again
doing spectroscopy to see this uh
splitting and then had a um a uh
destructive readout that involved a
complicated process in which various
voltages were tuned in such a way that a
Cooper pair could break and and tunnel
out acquiring some uh energy to break
from the bias voltages and and create a
tiny uh tunneling current in the circuit
so again uh microwaves in and a a quite
difficult noisy lowf frequency
measurements to see what
happened but then in uh uh
1999 yasu wrote the paper which got me
into the field I'd never heard of the
concept the quantum Computing I didn't
know there were crazy people thinking
about this possibility and he did this
Amazing Experiment where he uh with a
half a million doll uh Pico second pulse
generator moved the bias point of the
circuit to the degeneracy point so fast
that the system was then in a coherent
superposition of the two igen states and
it's the real time you know it's the
time domain analog of Robbie
oscillations in in a driven atom and
here you can see these uh beautiful uh
Robbie oscillations but look at the time
scale it's Pico
seconds and um uh but still it was the
first time that this sort of realtime
Quantum Dynamics had been seen due to
this coherent
splitting then uh and this is a you know
I don't have time to do the whole
history so I'm just picking out a few
highlights so this is uh quantonium from
the saay group and uh it was an
artificial atom tuned to a clock
transition to a place where the
splitting frequency is first order in
sensitive to um the control knobs that
you can turn uh some uh magnetic flux
and some bias voltage and if you you
know a fundamental theorem of
engineering is that if you can turn knob
the noise demon can also turn that knob
so you uh want to be at a place where
your first order sensitive insensitive
to the to those effects and this was I
remember Rob and I discussing this thing
uh just seemed to ring forever you know
half a microsc it was
incredible how how long the the
coherence was and this was the first
observation of ramsy fringes in a Sol
State Cubit and why was this important
because it's the thing we needed to
convince those pesky Amo physicists that
this was the real deal okay this is
their acid test for uh
coherence so that was uh incredibly
exciting and and the experiment was done
just before uh Michelle uh moved to Y
and really um really uh mve things
forward uh Hans Moy in Del um uh and uh
also in some experiments in
collaboration with yasu um uh developed
a kind of duel to these charge based
cubits the flux
Cubit and um John Martinez uh developed
a high fidelity readout it was 85% it
was like amazing uh High Fidelity for
those days and it it was going back to
his PhD thesis here you had two levels
that were deep enough in the well that
they could be your cubid you could have
a Robie drive but then if you wanted to
read it out you could check whether it
was in this state by exciting it to this
state and then having it tunnel out and
uh release a flood of energy as the
particle fell down the hill and that
flood of energy was big enough that he
got this amazingly High readout Fidelity
for the time
85% but unfortunately when uh you tried
to do this with two cubits that amazing
flood of energy wiped out the other
Cubit so in the end it wasn't uh uh it
was too
destructive but it was a it was a uh a
real advance in terms of readout
Fidelity uh then uh coming back to New
Haven uh with a couple people are here
in the room uh the transmon Cubit sort
of the world's simplest thing just uh a
little d pole antenna with the two
halves connected by a josen junction
it's not so little for an atom it's a
millimeter across the um the transition
dipole moment is several Cooper pairs
moving a millimeter which is a lot
bigger than the transition dipole moment
of uh of sodium for EXA and um it had
this wonderful feature that it was
exponentially insensitive to offset
charge noise and I you know uh people
that didn't experience those early days
won't understand why I had PTSD looking
at those old slides about
uh that involved charge so uh there's
just stuff in the substrate that moves
around and uh we can't fix that but we
can make a cubit that's insensitive to
that it's an artificial atom with atomic
number 10 to the 12 and yet the spectrum
is simpler than that of hydrogen and it
has a a comparable quality
Factor uh nowadays people many people
are making High Fidelity Gates here's
one example from will Oliver's group or
two examples a controlled phase gate uh
through a coupler between two transmons
and uh even higher Fidelity Gates
between two uh fonum cubits with a
transmon coupler so it's just been
tremendous progress you'll hear more
from other people during the week and in
Rob's uh dual rail talk on Friday I
think you'll also see some uh uh amazing
Fidelity
numbers uh and you know a key part of
the um the engineering is that uh you
need Quantum limited amplifiers to
detect the very tiny signals that uh uh
came out of come out of these systems
and there are many people many of whom
are in the audience uh who contribute to
this uh Conrad is is um is using them
now to search for Dark Matter axons with
our colleagues in in the right lab uh
here at Yale and uh Michelle enco used
the very high efficiency measurements to
to catch and even reverse a Quantum jump
in mid-flight so really a very important
engineering uh
developments okay so now on to really uh
circuit QED so we know that um QED is um
really the study of the effect of vacuum
fluctuation so the quantization of the
electromagnetic field in in the world
and it has many uh effects that you
learn about not at the beginning of your
quantum mechanics course but certainly
in graduate school it leads to
spontaneous emission of the first
excited state of hydrogen in 1.5 Nan
it renormalizes the mass of the electron
gives a splitting um um between the lamp
shift between the nominally degenerate
states of the hydrogen atom and we uh
the engineering we're trying to do uh is
to change the spectrum of the vacuum
fluctuations by putting them between
mirrors or even inside a super
connecting box if it's microwaves and uh
by changing that Spectrum you can ENG
engineer new properties and in
particular uh you can have the prel
effect to suppress the spontaneous
emission of the artificial atom uh uh by
not having any modes in the cavity uh at
that frequency that doesn't work in
macroscopic Optical uh systems because
it can still radiate this way but inside
a box if you take a transmon in free
space it has a spontaneous emission
lifetime of 100 NS can be a thousand
times or more longer inside one of these
boxes so that's very
important so here's the original gang uh
with the first experiment it's inside a
uh shielded copper box uh because we
were sure that all those cell phones
that were being invented in those days
uh were going to screw up the experiment
turns out they didn't um but it was
electromagnetically quiet so quiet
inside there that Dave Schuster could
sleep standing
up okay
so so what we did in in in this uh paper
led by Alexander blle uh a theory paper
was to get rid of all the DC stuff and
send in microwaves in and get microwaves
out and I didn't understand you know as
a matter physicist I didn't know
anything about Quantum measurements in
those days I had to learn this and this
really is sort of the prototypical
quantum measurement you send in the
microwaves they come back with a phase
shift that depends on the frequency of
the cavity which in turn depends on the
state of the Cubit and so you literally
entangle the Cubit with a meter the the
photons and then you read out the meter
and uh I learned so much uh from finally
understanding Quantum measurements uh
from thinking about this it was really
wonderful
time uh so uh uh Andreas and Dave uh
managed to get the vacuum Robbie
splitting uh for the first time in a
circuit and I remember when trying to
calculate how big was it going to be and
you know get the units right and
everything and uh it came out 100
megahertz and I thought oh my gosh
that's that's pretty gigantic but then
you know there was charge noise and it
was horrible but they managed to uh they
managed to get at work sneaking in at
night when things were the elevator
wasn't running or something and um and
that worked and that Illustrated strong
coupling that the the coupling the
dipole coupling was bigger than the
dissipation then uh Dave and Jay went
into the limit where the second order
effects of the coupling the dispersive
coupling were still so big they were
bigger than the dissipation and then you
could count individual microwave photons
proving that they really are particles
not
waves and uh and um also could see this
uh purcel suppression uh honey Pike did
a 3D cavity experiment and Matt RoR uh
worked on making these cavities uh much
longer lived and now we have new designs
and and the the uh it's amazing now uh
the lifetimes you can get um out of
these
things um so the Santa Barbara group um
uh uh started making superpositions of
small numbers of photons here's the
theoretical vigner function and the
experimental reconstructed VOR function
for 0 plus 1 through 0 + 5 uh from our
friends here and uh so we're Mo you know
and Rob and Company did an experiment uh
seeing the electric field between a
superp position of zero and one
photons and uh we were really into the
world of controlling individual Quant
and then uh this first uh two Cubit uh
Quantum processor with the two cubits
talking to each other through the
quantum bus a virtual exchange of
microwave photons that was developed uh
in in Rob's lab uh uh by these guys and
we were so excited to you know run a
Quantum
algorithm with two cubits and uh okay
it's a start you have to start somewhere
and uh I think Jerry uh will tell us uh
about some minor scaling up that they've
been
doing in in the last few years uh and
that's we look forward to hearing that
uh is going to be exciting so here's the
Gang excited about uh two Cubit
entanglement and uh and algorithms in uh
2007 and uh Dave doesn't look that
excited but uh I think he I think he was
happy I don't
know okay so um so I'm gonna uh that's
the past I want to talk about um more
recent past of quantum error correction
and I'm just going to briefly mention
things uh with three different
experiments using bosonic codes which
have gotten to uh slightly Beyond break
even and more recently substantially
Beyond and then I'll I'll say a little
bit more uh on the theory end later so
um so uh the first code uh was the cat
code that was um uh developed by our uh
with in collaboration with Theory
collaborators and uh experiment in Rob's
lab from uh in
2016 uh uh getting slightly uh above
break even using Schrodinger cat states
with either superposition of two
positions or two
momenta then Luan Sun who an Alum from
here uh did a nice two nice experiments
using the binomial code which leang Jang
and I uh uh threw together as a summer
project with an undergraduate uh mariio
Michael and uh uh got uh just above
break even um in the conser correct
conservatively defined way um in
uh uh
2023 and in the same issue of nature uh
Vlad CAC and Michelle's uh group uh did
a Quantum correction using these
beautiful uh grid States
gkp uh code words and there was uh um an
improved tantalum transmon a um a
reinforcement learning agent that helped
improve this and on the theory side um a
nice uh new semi-autonomous
stabilization protocol that avoided the
measurement and feedback uh scheme uh
and all of those things combined to get
us up to an error correction gain of of
2.3 and really
impressively uh you could do 400 cycles
of quantum error
correction uh uh before losing the
information so that's really in a class
by
itself okay so now I want to turn to the
Future and tell you about a few things
that are in this monster paper that I've
been saying for some time is almost
ready uh it's 12 authors 137 Pages 533
references and we're still working on it
uh and it's to try to formalize in a
computer science sense some of the
instruction set architectures that
experimentalists now are using to
control uh hybrid systems consisting of
discrete variable cubits and continuous
variable oscillators and this is uh
primarily a C2 QA project but the the
yel part is also um supported by
Aro so imagine just as a you know a
theorist's uh Hardware architecture that
you had a two or maybe three-dimensional
grid of harmonic
oscillators connected by beam Splitters
which unlike Optical beam Splitters
they're they're microwave activated
using three or four wave mixing you can
turn them on and off and you can adjust
their rate and their phase to to move
photons from one box to the the other
and each box has a single Cubit
dispersively coupled to
it and um let's compare that to an ion
trap we're going to we're going to have
Gates that are similar to ion traps spin
dependent forces but in an iron trap
each of the spins is coupled to all of
the modes and they like to advertise
this gives them all to all coupling uh
but it's complicated and you have to you
can get cross talk and there are various
uh
complications uh although you know still
works extremely well and there but
there's no uh controlled coupling
between these modes whereas here you can
be talking to a single mode very cleanly
with no cross talk and then swap that
mode through here to somewhere else and
have it talk to another Cubit and come
back so that you can communicate and
intangle the cubits or the uh
cavities so uh there are sort of three
possible abstract machine models that
this Hardware could present to the
software it could be Cubit Cubit Centric
with the uh Ban's just playing the role
of a communication bus that's highly
controllable you could have swapping
going this way and swapping going that
way at the same time as long as you
schedule the swaps to avoid collisions
it could be bosonic mode Centric where
the only purpose of the cubits is to
give you universal control over the
oscillators which in turn contain
perhaps Quantum error correction bosonic
codes and um it could be hybrid in which
you have access at the comp at the
software level to both the discret
variable and continuous variable degrees
of freedom that could be very good for
Quantum simulators for spins or fans
coupled to boson such as uh lattice
gauge theories which is one of the
things that we're working on in C2 QA
and uh some particular version of this
at at uh uh in the Dual rail encoding
you'll hear about on
Friday so uh in order to uh produce to
program this thing you have to produce
unitaries that's what quantum computers
do and um so so here's a short crash
course in uh control theory for these
hybrid systems so by by driving a
two-level system with classical drives
can you control it well in some rotating
wave approximation you get control of
the p x and the p y operators and
there's a fundamental theorem from
control theory that if the Lee algebra
of the available controls defined by
their
commutator uh spans the space of all
operators you're you have uh
controlability
and uh uh for fortunately the commutator
of the Pali X and Y gives p z and
therefore you have uh able to generate
arbitary su2 Le group rotations on this
single Cubit using only two classical
controls the same is not true for a
harmonic oscillator your two classical
drives cosine and S couple you in the
some rotating frame to uh position and
momentum and unfortunately the
commutator those guys is just a number
and therefore the algebra closes and you
cannot do anything other than displace
the oscillator in Phase space you can
make um coherent States but you can't
make Fox States or gkp states or
binomial code words and um we know also
physically that's closely related to the
fact that the level spacing is
uniform but in this dispersive uh
coupling Hamilton Onan where you have a
cubit coupled to the cavity and their
frequencies are different then you get
this dispersive coupling and by applying
drives to the cavity and the Cubit you
can uh reduce this nonlinearity to
something slightly less nonlinear to
just uh X and P times one of the P
matrices uh so if you look at the the
commutator algebra for that that set of
controls for example X the oscillator
position time p x momentum time p y you
get something interesting because the
patri is anti-c commute you get
conditional squeezing hamiltonian it
will squeeze the position if Z is + one
and anti and squeeze the momentum if Z
is minus
one if you take further commutators you
see that the polom grows and grows in
degree and the oper operator algebra
does not close and you get universal
control so there knowing that there are
standard tricks strotter zuzuki to add
control terms and Baker Campbell house
dorf to multiply them in the form of
commutators and you can then generate
the most General
hamiltonian that a single Cubit coupled
to a single oscillator can have namely
some polinomial of X and P for the
oscillator
and a vector of three pols dotted into
the P system and that gives you uh
universal
control so there are many uh uh
instruction sets that we consider in
this paper but I'll stick to one example
here which is the control displacement
which is generated exponentials of that
control set and plus single Cubit
rotations around axes on the on the um
equator of the block sphere and by
alternating these you're doing a kind of
quantum signal processing uh extended
to um uh this uh where the where the
rotation angles on the Cubit are now
Quantum objects themselves that don't
necessarily commute the position and
momentum of the oscillator and so here
are some examples from Alec ik Bush's
paper in the from the deay group
uh this is the characteristic function
for what is obviously a highly squeezed
State here is the same for the binomial
code words this is all data and this is
the gkp code words and these can be made
in very shallow circuits this is a very
expressive Gat set in the machine
learning
language um so what can we do with these
well uh the first thing is you can do
the world's most complicated single
cubit
rotation uh by um uh doing a series of
uh controlled and uncontrolled
displacements in such a way by applying
these spin dependent forces to the
oscillator if the Cubit is in one you
make a counterclockwise circuit in Phase
space and pick up one Berry phase and if
Cubit is zero you pick up the opposite
and the net effect of that is no matter
what was in the cavity before it's the
same
unchanged but the Cubit gets a phase
kick back which rotates it around the
z-axis and here you can see The ramsy
Fringe oscillations measuring that uh
rotation so can we uh extend that to do
something interesting within this Cubit
Centric abstract Machine model where the
cavities do something to the Cubit not
the other way around and Kevin Smith has
developed a uh series of entangling
gates so the rzz Theta this two Cubit
rotation you can achieve let's say
between this Cubit and that Cubit by
doing a control displacement in the
first cavity then moving the contents of
that cavity down here doing a different
control displacement with that guy
moving it back and forth a couple of
times and uh you can get one of four
trajectories depending on the four
values of Z1 and Z2 and if Z1 and Z2 are
the
same uh you make a a clockwise Loop
either here or here depending whether
it's z0 or 1 one and if they're the
opposite you go counterclockwise either
here or here picking up opposite phase
and therefore doing this gate now you
can there are simple you could uh have
bigger swap networks so that you
entangle this Cubit with that Cubit by
swapping uh through some path this way
and unlike mulmer Sorenson and iron
traps you don't do this to everybody you
select who you do this to and you can do
several of them in
parallel uh Kevin's also found similar
circuits that will produce cot zzz of
theta to 3 Cubit tofly Gates Etc uh so
uh so that's a nice example of using the
cavities as communication Bus Plus
things that uh can entangle uh the
cubits in a cubit Centric model in a
bosan Centric model we want to use the
same Gat set to uh do things to the
oscillators using the cubits with the
same gate set and one example is um uh
an improved circuit for gkp bosonic code
stabilization uh and Gates and uh this
is what was used the first part of this
is what was used in the recent uh
experiment from uh Michelle's group so
I'll just remind you that the idealized
gkp wave functions are are a picket
fence evenly spaced in position and its
Fu transform is a piot fence easily
evenly spaced in
momentum and these are defined by
stabilizers two stabilizers which are a
momentum boost and a position
displacement you can see understand the
displac you know if you displace this by
a latus Conant it comes back to itself
so it's a plus one igen state of that
and um so the stabilizers in the code uh
are translations in face space how do we
measure the IG value of those
stabilizers well unlike the P
stabilizers you're used to they're not
plus one or minus one they have a phase
that lives on the unit circle and
they're sensitive that phase is
sensitive to small displacement errors
of this uh lattice of states and the way
you measure the IG value associated with
that unary is with a a phase Kickback
circuit like this um much as was used um
uh to uh in that Ramsey Fringe
experiment I showed you so so uh you can
reinterpret this momentum boost when you
put a z there instead of a momentum
boost that depends on whether Z is plus
one or minus one you can think of it as
a rotation of the Cubit around the
z-axis that depends on the position of
the oscillator and if the positions are
on a lattice and they're in the right
place that rotation is a multiple of 2
pi and doesn't give you any change in
the state of the
Cubit but if there's an error you pick
up some
signal well that's fine for the ideal
world but in practice you have to have a
gaussian envelope and finite squeezing
of these picket Fen and so there's some
Quantum uncertainty in the rotation
angle of the Cubit and it's not always
exactly 2 pi a multiple of 2 pi even
when there's no actual error because of
this Quantum uncertainty so that's a
problem and um and also you know we have
to uh deal with this fact that there's
an overall Gan envelope so how do we
handle this and uh it's too complicated
to explain now but there's a a wonderful
uh autonomous protocol rather than
measuring the small shifts you run this
circuit uh developed uh by these folks
uh where you have the the
stabilizer in there uh in a with a but
with a controlled gate as I showed you
and then you pre and post pen that with
very small um perpendicular
displacements in Phase space which
actually turn out if you choose them
correctly
to cancel out the effect of these scalan
fluctuations in position and then rather
than measuring and feedback you just uh
reset the Cubit uh or measure and and
reset it um uh and it pumps away the
entropy um uh from the system without
having to do direct
feedback um so that's uh that that was a
interesting step forward now if you want
to have the gkp code and it's
interesting fact that the P unitaries
like uh the X Y or Z unitaries are just
displacements they're very easy to do
when you just send a classical pulse and
change the position of the oscillator
but how in the world could we do a p
rotation let's say around the x-axis
which is a superposition of not doing a
displacement and doing a
displacement those are sort of
macroscopically distinguished things how
do you do that and it turns out sh Singh
has uh who's working with me and shti
Puri uh has modified this small big
small uh stabilization protocol that
does autonomously does the error
correction it just splits this middle
step into two pieces and inserts a cubit
rotation in between so it it actually
takes almost exactly the same length of
time as the stabilization process and
the stabilization keeps working and so
it protects against Photon loss in the
cavity or small face based displacements
and it also has some favorable
properties with respect to the Ancilla
def phasing errors and this looks a
little bit like ordinary gate
teleportation but actually it's not
because this second half of the circuit
is not the inverse of the first half and
uh so that's a uh something that's being
written up
now uh so um there are many open
questions uh how do you do what's the
analog of randomized benchmarking for
continuous variable systems the there
are analoges between gaussian operations
and Clifford operations on cubits but
the gaussian operations are non-compact
they involve bof Transformations not uh
uh su2 they don't form a two design for
the theorist um do we have we've
learning how to do this non Alan Quantum
signal processing using both momentum
boosts and position displacements as
rotation angles on the cubits but is
there a formal Theory to give us
convergence bounds on how well that
works and is there a nice way to
construct uh useful unitaries other than
numerical optimization and we've made
some progress on that but still lots
more work needs to be
done uh so uh this is a very incomplete
history uh and I just want to say thank
you to the many many people all of whom
I I can't uh list here uh that I've had
the pleasure of working with uh recently
inside yqi from postto students uh
undergrads and even a high school
student and uh many thanks to my uh
faculty colleagues uh with whom I'm
working and to uh a few more that we're
excited to be recruiting right now and
finally uh it happens that this month is
a um palindromic birthday for Rob when
expressed in binary
and so I want to wish rob a happy
birthday and thank him for so many years
of just fantastic
collaboration
[Applause]
[Music]